si acá en la región de heart quien
continúa esa contraofensiva lanzada por
el ejército ucraniano hace dos días en
las últimas horas las tropas de ucrania
han recuperado algunas posiciones dicen
que han librado también algunas aldeas y
hay informaciones de que el ejército
ruso estaría replegando por otra parte
una última hora es que rusia ha
destruido un arsenal de armas
occidentales aquí cerca de donde nos
encontramos en la ciudad de kharkiv se
trataría de la estación de bobo dujo
precisamente en estos momentos en el que
también hay informaciones de que otro
ataque ha afectado un museo
una otra emergencia que está sufriendo
este país es también el
desabastecimiento de gasolina ya lo
pueden ver detrás de mí o hay una
larguísima cola de vehículos que están a
la espera de poder abastecerse este
problema atañe sobre todo a los
ciudadanos a la gente común porque en
estos momentos el ejército de los
trabajadores humanitarios tienen
prioridad y por tanto sí que pueden
acceder con mayor facilidad a la
gasolina que hay disponible en ucrania
en estos momentos